digital leaders have experienced
extraordinary growth over the past
several years
during this time mackenzie has partnered
with many of these players to unlock the
power of ai and advanced analytics to
drive innovation transform operations
and create entirely new business models
quantum black china enables us to tap
into deeper global talent and
cutting-edge technologies combine
leading minds with leading technology
this creates a new source of competitive
advantage which we call hybrid
intelligence
okay that creepy video was just one of
dozens that you can find on consulting
giant mckinsey's twitter and web pages
now despite the bad look the bad music
u.s companies co-mingling with chinese
entities it's nothing new
but should it be allowed if these same
companies consult with our own pentagon
our next guest is trying to put a stop
to this introducing legislation that
would end this compromise practice of
double dipping joining us now is
missouri senator josh hawley member of
homeland security committee
senator my first question is
how is this not already barred by u.s
law given the fact that
you know we don't get that type of
reciprocity when dealing with sensitive
matters that china has access to
yeah that's certainly the case laura
listen it should absolutely be illegal
and this bill would make it so here's
the real thing we've got these
corporations lots of them who want to
take a buck from uncle sam who want to
get contracts from uncle sam but they're
happy to sell out our technology our
jobs our workers and they've been doing
it for years and it's time to put a stop
to it the least we can do is say if you
get a contract with the defense
department of the united states you
shouldn't be advising the chinese
government and that's what this
legislation would do now senator also
president biden has been
dragging his feet although we know which
way he's going to go and making this
decision on whether to lift trump's
tariffs on china
here's how the white house actually
responded to questions yesterday
the way that it was handled by the last
administration
was
was you know they it got it was bungled
if you if you if you i'm going to be
really uh
you know honest here it was not done in
an effective way
senator bungled trump took china head on
really smartly they did that long report
bob lighthizer the ustr probably the
most talented one we've ever had in our
history
this was done meticulously
he didn't cower to the chinese like
biden is obviously beginning to do
you know i think that the tariffs on
china were some of the best things that
president trump did and we all know
what's going to happen here joe biden's
going to cave he is going to roll over
for the chinese communist party he's
going to let them have everything back
that they wanted and all i can say is if
you like what you're getting from biden
if you want to send more jobs overseas
to china if you want to have to buy our
energy from china if you want to be
dependent on china then joe biden's your
guy because that's his entire policy but
for those of us who want jobs in america
good paying jobs manufacturing jobs in
this country those tariffs are important
and i think we shouldn't roll them back
laura we ought to be strengthening them
that ought to be our policy yeah bob
lighthizer actually wrote an op-ed in
the wall street journal today that was
brilliant talking about how lifting the
tariffs everyone knows it's not going to
have any real effect effect on inflation
it's only going to make chinese products
stronger in the united states and hurt
u.s manufacturing at a time where i
thought biden was supposed to be
improving u.s manufacturing that's i
guess out the window totally
well you know here's the deal the
chinese government and the chinese
economy is dependent on slave labor i
mean let's just tell the truth it is
slave labor that powers much of the
chinese economy and what effectively is
happening is the bite administration
wants u.s workers to have to compete
against slave labor which will end up
strengthening the slave labor it'll fund
them it'll impoverish our workers it'll
send our industry overseas this is what
the liberals and
unfortunately many republicans have been
pushing for decades now we know what the
results are the results are jobs leaving
this country the results are hollowed
out industry we need to reverse all of
that and that's why it is important to
say that we're going to hold china
accountable that we're going to protect
and nurture our own industry in this
country and we're going to protect
american workers that'll be our policy
senator hawley um there's so much i want
to get to you tonight but unfortunately
i guess we're out of time thank you so
much for joining us as always hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else